Chris will be on the call with Marv
Albert Pacers bucks tonight at 8:00
Eastern on TNT
all right LeBrons now fourth on the
all-time scoring list does that change
anything for you Chris no I mean I knew
he was a great player if it doesn't it
doesn't it doesn't change anything he's
a great player again I think no athlete
has had a pressure before entering any
league no athlete has had social media
and that pressure no athlete was paid
100 million dollars from Nike before
they came into play besides LeBron so
for him to pass every expectation to me
that's the greatest accomplishment but
you know you can look at a lot of things
you know you know you could come I just
think there needs to be a line in the
sand and no more comparisons because it
just can't be just you know Jordan
didn't come straight out of high school
what is your mother played four more
years Jordan played in a different era
you know so I I'm kind of worn out of
the comparisons because I just I think
you still have to talk about him being
better than Kobe you can't jump up to
Jordan I don't think numbers just mean
it and I think maybe here's the greatest
teammate of all time instead of
individual players so when you get into
the weeds of it I've heard it's really
good arguments and I can agree with
those but the overall arguments I'm not
sure because one day Durant's gonna
break all and those nothing Durant will
actually break Kings record so it means
a lot that he did then I'm
congratulations very happy for him but
it doesn't do anything in the argument
of who's better to me yeah I was
wondering about that because you played
against these guys so you're sort of
that bridge guy that you know what Mike
was like and obviously what LeBron is
like but I I mean you're right about
Kobe he sort of gets lost in this I'm
not sure why but he's in between the two
but he doesn't give he's not given
enough credit I think for what he did
how he did it because he said I'm gonna
be as good as I'm gonna go right at Mike
I'm gonna have my number 24 not 23 like
I'm going right at you I want to be
better than you I'm gonna play just like
you did and have your same style so
you're gonna compare the comparison is
really Kobe to Mike not LeBron to Mike
yeah and the vulnerability that's
something we really never I don't want
to get I don't want to start nothing
this morning but when you really think
about used to think about Kobe style in
Michael Jordan style they were going to
willed their teams to win and if you
couldn't shoot a shot in the corner then
I'm not passing it to you I'm gonna
score the ball cuz we need to win
tonight yeah and so me as a player that
have gone like I'm sure three for 20 in
the game and it hurts your feelings and
you got to come back to their game it's
a little bit of Honor in that if you're
not just taking bad shots every every
night because it's messed up as a player
when you shoot 3 for 17 4 for 15 and if
you want it too many times as a great
Clair you can keep it around 50% if you
don't take any risk and the thing was
Jordan and Kobe that was so amazing with
him is it took so much risk to
difficulties on their shots the fact
that when other guys weren't knocking
him down
they were just will himself and and I'm
always you know I always reminded that
picture of Jordan I think he's checking
magic when he has like the tights up
under his shorts he pulls the shorts up
he's at half-court lookin magic in his
eyes and checking them you know and so I
just remember those guys saying don't
forget that I'll check him I'll check
him now I've never you know this many
years into your career 16 years I don't
know if anyone is clades weightless
LeBrons play but I still think you know
it's a table and he's Jordan Kobe all
them are at the table I don't know if
anyone that says that that just at the
head of the table because they're doing
it today that's that's all okay but kids
growing up now our argument will they
try to emulate LeBron the way the
players of a different era like you guys
we're trying to emulate Michael or are
they gonna emulate James Harden or Steph
Curry are they gonna skip by LeBron
because how can you try to emulate what
LeBron does well hopefully um relate
with LeBron does cuz he's a great
teammate and what I mean by that is he
makes the correct basketball players so
a lot of people no matter how good
you are if you don't have that IQ it
shows and it's embarrassing so LeBrons
like he was just off the charts and so
you can't be that player now that knows
every play on the other team that knows
when you get a pickup that knows your
strengths so that when you draw a
double-team you know who to get to but
yeah I think you know the game is
courage right now I mean couriers you
know in a great way and and I teased him
like he messed up the game now walking
to a gym and kids shooting threes but
that's what Dominique and Jordan did
they messed up the game cuz we used to
walk in and dunk before we read it was
stretch so let me that's just the way
it's gonna be but I think courage is his
size he shows that the game as long as
you have skill it doesn't matter I tell
you all he's one of the best ball
handlers that we've had and what he's
doing you know I love because growing up
in Isaiah Thomas fan growing up a fan of
all the guards he's just taken their
game to another another level because he
has freedom he has skillset that maybe
they didn't have in the freedom that
they didn't have it so I think you're
gonna see a lot more people emulator
with trying to turn around while the
balls in the air after shooting the 345
feet and stand if it goes in also
looking at the Greek freak and Ben
Simmons the fact that they're this good
they've gotten this far and they can't
shoot how does that happen Chris it
happens because they're very good and it
happens because there's no more shot
blockers name yet so they're very good
and now you don't have let's say and use
not to do [ __ ] but you don't have a Rik
Smits and Adelle Davis so where if one
is being pulled out you still have
another shot blocker inside an old
traditional game it was a foreign five
the five was being he could block shots
in the four could even come in and help
now that five could be a four man the
rant could be playing the five and so
therefore if you're Ben Simmons and
you're on and you got curry checking you
know buddy someone to block the shot
better side go right in and take it so I
think there are less shot blockers
there's no matumbo even though I do I
love Rudy so people go Bears game you
know no morning or Bradley those type of
guys so I think it's a little bit easier
but I think those guys have a much
better skill set or more freedom than
guys that were my high hat back then to
you know be able to take 30 dribbles
weight double-team comes Rachel
double-team leaves and still they will
attack inside but it's fun too
those big guys do what they do with the
ball I was wondering about the Mount
Rushmore of impactful players like they
left they left their mark I look at
Steph Curry
I look at Dirk Nowitzki I look at
Michael Jordan and I'm talking about
modern basketball and and I would
probably put magic in there as well
because he he said to every you probably
wanted to play point guard you know at
some point in your in your life what
what Steph is done to the three-point
shot what Mike did - you know the game
dunking flying and Dirk what he did to
big men that you can shoot outside and
shoot three-pointers there can you think
of anyone else I would put birdie at the
table before Dirk because magic is the
one that made us what a play point guard
we had to watch it a bird is the one the
first big man we saw shoot threes okay
yeah be there be no dirty if it weren't
for birds so bird definitely I mean Dirk
definitely took it to the next level not
talking about Dirk in any way bad at all
but Dirk is not bird and the bird to the
shot eight threes again we looked at
first I like three and a half again and
so and this bird came down on the break
even though he wasn't the most athletic
he had to fill the wings and lay it up
because they didn't want him going to
the corner the spacing wasn't like that
so he didn't have those opportunities
but we saw him shoot threes we saw him
when a three-point contest which is
shooting shirt on and hold the finger up
so if the bird is the one that started
that night I totally agree with you as
far as those guys being kind of pillars
in the game I say Gary Payton on defense
believe it not because I saw a lot of
guards want to throw lobs or want to
play defense like Gary Payton he made it
sexy to play defense to talk junk and to
kind of bring that out so no I I totally
agree when you talk about those pillars
of the game but you missed it bird by a
couple of years I think 10 you two years
I missed about one year the year that I
came in he had just retired I think a
year and a half but I got to play
against him in the dream team that last
year of his healthy basketball and I'm
telling you like we wanted to go in and
going into there I wanted to see Barkley
he was my favorite player Jordan
and bird it was it was it was those
three bust far heads the shoulders above
the rest you know magic as well but you
we wanted to see we wanted to see bird
and be able to practice what I'm see how
he worked our see our shot see the junk
that he talked constantly I mean it was
like it was you know was the one of the
best moments in life because you are
with guys and killers of the game it's
changed you like that yeah but you're
you got Jordan who talks you got Barkley
who talks and then you got bird who
talks who talked the most when you
played against the dream team you think
my generation grew up talking so much
and everything else and I I don't know
who talking about the best the best was
my man Rodney Rogers strong fast quick
athletic and birds just set them up in a
corner they someone drives to the corner
stock and passed out the bird and here
you see where I need riders take up full
sprint and I'm talking about you know
how how Dianne block that shot a couple
weeks ago yeah that's where like like
where Ronnie Rogers came from except
unlike the young kids that shot the shot
in the middle of champion in the mid air
bird says welcome to the parachute Club
rookie watches him go by choose the ball
and like curry does with bird here
because he shot it and just kept walking
down like shaking his hair like these
time youngsters they'll never get it do
you see any comparisons you brought up
Rodney Rogers
and when I was asked about Zion I said
you know I for some reason and maybe
because they're left-handed but you know
they were big athletic guys who were
mobile and I I see a little bit of
Rodney Rogers in Zion Williams and
everybody wants to say Charles Barkley I
do see Rodney Rogers in Zion yeah I
don't see much Charles Barkley in Zion I
do see Ronnie Rodgers it makes so much
sense now that he said like that Brian
Rodgers could shoot better yeah but
wasn't as athletic but yeah I think
Ronnie Rogers and this is another guy
McGann he is better than these guys but
James Forrestal Georgia Tech I know for
myself I've never seen a guy like
that strong I mean I knew a country
strong was after I played against him
and Corliss Williamson those guys like
that that I mean maybe never lifted a
weight but could push a car out the way
if they needed to and so with him yeah I
definitely think I think definitely
think Rodney Vaz would be a great
comparison for that tell Marv we settle
Oh have fun tonight Pacers and the Bucks
and by the way you're still broke Tom it
was hard I had him on yesterday and he
he was just say he said you made him cry
that you didn't go to Michigan State he
still loves you but you made him crying
he can't get over yeah no I I love
comments just think about this sounds a
great guy but you just think about this
you know I'm no one recruiting the
country all this stuff and Tom was taken
over coach dirty coat was leaving and
you know you're usually cooler with the
assistant coach so he's all recruited me
and he became a friend even though I was
in high school like he became that to me
and I didn't go there I was upset he was
the first person that I called even
before I called Michigan to tell him
that I was going there so he actually
knew before anyone and this is what's
really crazy four years later you know
who plays on the Michigan State team my
brother Jason played there for three
years and because Tom recruited him
that's just who Tom is he knew our
family he knew my brothers and sisters
since he was coming into the house and
they were little crawling all over him
and so I can't stand enough about the
man time is the fire he has inside and
and even when basketball is not going on
he sees a heck a lot of fun to be around
him his family so uh you know that's my
man
Thank You Chris have fun tonight we
always appreciate your time see well
Turner Sports NBA analyst you know he's
one of my favorites but he's one of my
favorites because he sort of stumbles
along a story that you're you can bring
up a topic and then he has he just has a
story or two and that's what's fun
because you know they can give you
answers but when they tell you stories
that's when it's fun for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience channel 239
on Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
you
[Music]